pour en parler nous recevons gibran
bassil ex ministre libanais des affaires
étrangères chef du courant patriotique
libre bonsoir j'ai vraiment facile merci
d'être avec nous nous accorder cet
entretien en direct sur arte france le
liban qui affiche donc une dette de 92
milliard de dollar soit 170 % de son pib
l'état on vient de le dire qui annonce
être en cessation de paiement en tant
que responsable politique on imagine
votre désarroi comment le liban at il pu
en arriver là
assez des politiques monétaires et
économiques qui ont été adoptés depuis
de l'entente et la faillite était bien
prévu et on n'a pas pu changer cette
politique là on est tombé dans une crise
très aigu et on est obligés maintenant
le voir et à remettre en question tout
ce qui a été adopté dans notre passé le
gouvernement a adopté finalement un
premier pas qui est un plan de secours
compréhensif un plan monétaire financier
économique et social et ça c'est un
premier pas qui ouvre qui ouvre les
négociations avec le fonds monétaire
international et qui met en question
toutes les politiques du passé
là il faut revoir les mesures anti
corruption parce que ça c'est un
problème majeur au payés pour donner la
confiance à l'état et par le peuple par
le peuple libanais et la communauté
internationale aussi il faut adopter une
politique monétaire où on ne fixe lui le
taux de change dollar livre libanaise et
où on a donc des taux d'intérêt assez
bas une troisième chose c'est que il
faut faire
l'obturation de la dette et il faut
encourager et préserver le secteur
public
l'initiative personnelle et l'état
libanais doit assurer ses
responsabilités en créant un fonds
mon état souverain qui peut ouvrir la
voie à un partenariat complet entre le
secteur privé et secteur public
ça c'est des mesures qui n'ont jamais
été adoptés au liban et être vraiment de
à cette crise une opportunité de revivre
notre économie de revoir le liban des
années 50 et des années 60 et de
préserver un pilier essentiel de notre
liberté économique parce que le libre
c'est le pays des libertés la liberté
d'expression la liberté de croyance il
faut toujours avoir cette liberté
économique qui a été un pilier essentiel
de notre pays
justement j'ai bien vivre cette aide qui
semble nécessaire aujourd'hui demandé au
fmi un est ce que vous ne craignez pas
d'une certaine manière elle semble
nécessaire d'un côté mais ne
pourrait-elle pas se retourner contre le
liban pense notamment à l'exemple
argentin
non franchement si ces conditions ce
cloisons avec les réformes nécessaires
il faut considérer ça comme un
encouragement à adopter les réformes
tant attendues par notre peuple et par
la communauté internationale si c'est
une forme d'hégémonie ou deux mais mise
sur le pays on doit nécessairement la
refuser tant que ça ne touche pas à
notre souveraineté
moi je la considère comme un
encouragement à adopter les réformes
nécessaires et c'est là où le liban doit
savoir comment négocier pour alléger les
mesures les taxations et tout ça et pour
en profiter pour à profiter du programme
de fonds monétaires ça c'est notre
décision
c'est notre décision souveraine qui peut
faire la différence iations entre ce qui
est et ce qui est comme des conditions
politiques pas accepter aujourd'hui quel
est votre regard sur la gestion
justement vous l'avez dit il faut
négocier et bien négocier pour que l'on
aura compris que le liban ne perde pas
sa sa souveraineté nationale quel est le
regard que vous portez sur la gestion
par le nouveau gouvernement des scènes
diab
vous savez c'est un gouvernement qui
travaille qui a l'intention de changer
les choses on a vraiment besoin d'un
changement majeur surtout au niveau de
la corruption il faut il faut admettre
qu'on a échoué
jusqu'à maintenant on a fait la bataille
mais on n'a pas gagné encore bon il faut
leur donner la chance un peu de temps
pour eux pour prouver leur crédibilité
et chose qui a été fait au niveau de la
crise sanitaire
parce que le liban est parmi les rayer
les pays qui ont réussi
premièrement à avoir une réaction rapide
à prendre les mesures de confinement
même préventif dans ce sens là et le
peuple libanais a aussi montré une prise
de conscience collective c'est
l'immunité de notre peuple la propreté
des individus et de la société qui ont
prouvé que le liban a toujours montré
que c'est un pays qui est en place et
civilisé qui peuvent faire face à
n'importe quelle crise
là on a refait pas un crise politique
crise sanitaire crise économique et
financière et même on a une capacité
d'adaptation très élevé et on peut en
sortir emplois à notre pays et on parce
que le liban va survivre comme toujours
un oasis de prospérité et de stabilité
et de liberté c'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite gibran bassil en tout cas il
n'empêche il ya des manifestations on
les voit sur les écrans des télévisions
qui se poursuivent bravant d'ailleurs
les règles du confinement lier cette
crise du coronavirus certains
manifestants disent eh bien voilà on
préfère mourir de ce virus que de faim
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur répondre
même si vous n'êtes plus oser fermer en
tant que responsable politique qu'est ce
qu'on peut répondre à sa libre jamais
vous dire c'est un pays comme on dit
éternelle et on va surgir au virus et à
lhassa on vous rappelle qu'en 1915
on a une crise qui est beaucoup plus dur
on a même perdu le tiers de notre
population et on a récupéré notre
souveraineté après ça on a eu le gras
libres alors là c'est un cri et seront
toujours et on a une grande foi un
exposé un autre pays
je dis aux libanais et à la communauté
internationale
ayez confiance dans ce pays qui est
nécessité pour la diversité dans la
région pour la liberté et pour toujours
avoir un pays modèle qui croit vraiment
à la doit au doigt la différence et
c'est une chose nécessaire parce que
appelez le comme il l'a été
on tourne vers une crise internationale
et on a besoin des pays modèles comme le
liban qui peuvent faire face un
changement radical qui attend l'ordre
mondial et on appelait avec un pays très
petit mais un pays qui est toujours très
justement on parle de changement
certainement au liban on en parle un
petit peu partout dans le monde que
cette crise pourrait peut-être être
l'occasion de changer
les choses si vous appelez de vos voeux
justement une mutation une
transformation du liban ce serait
laquelle
en premier lieu je ne vois pas que le
liban peut perdre son image de diversité
et cette diversité à tous les niveaux au
niveau religieux au nouveau
confessionnelles au niveau culturel et
je ne vois pas une mutation dans le sens
où le liban peut tourner son visage de
l'occident ni même d'être déracinée de
lorient ssao je vois la nécessité d'un
pays qui peut être toujours le pont
entre les civilisations
alors cette mutation vers un régime
politique différent ou un régime
économique des différents c'est une
chose qui peut être accepté par le
peuple libanais et humains mis sur ce
pays soit par une faction de l'été de
l'intérieur l'extérieur c'est aussi une
chose qui n'est pas le faisait vous
savez le liban est un pays d'équilibré à
tous les niveaux et là aussi il faut
apprendre de son modèle d'équilibré vous
avoir une économie qui lit peut avoir
cet équilibre entre tous les secteurs au
niveau du tourisme de l'agriculture de
l'industrie des services ce qui a amené
à cette crise et que libre le liban a
été fixé seulement dans un seul sens
celui des services
là il faut reprendre cette diversité
économique et on reprend impayés qui a
toujours été un espace de prospérité
dans cette région c'est une nécessité et
pour le liban et pour l'europe et pour
le bassin méditerranéen
aujourd'hui on a entendu des
manifestants le revendiquer souvent dans
les cortèges
est-ce que
un mouvement citoyen nous semblerait
être un début de solution peut être une
alternative possible dans votre pays
pour se sortir en tout cas de cette
crise politique
oui on espère franchement on considère
que c'est aussi une opportunité pour
passer un état civil un état laïc ils
ont tourné un état civil mais la laïcité
de l'état c'est pour nous c'est une
nécessité mais doit avoir un consensus
national
parce que vous comprenez la complexité
de la situation avec 18 confessions dans
le pays
c'est pas facile à avoir un consensus
dans ce sens mais oui c'est une
opportunité que le peuple libanais s'est
révolté contre ce système confessionnel
et là c'est une chance de changer même
d'avoir une décentralisation une
décentralisation administrative et
financière et beaucoup de changements
nous attendent
c'est un début cette se plaint de
réforme ce plan de de salut économique
c'est un premier pas dans le bon sens et
on espère y réussir et que la communauté
internationale nous donne la chance je
sais que le liban a échoué dans le passé
mais on est on est quand même encerclé
par pas mal de crise et la dernière a
été celle de la syrie est celle de la
présence de 40 % de notre population 2
millions de syriens de palestiniens soit
200 par kilomètre carré qui ont causé un
une paire de 43 milliards de dollars de
l'an les la dernière période ce qui ce
qui équivaut à presque 90 % de notre
produit national brut
et ça c'est un fardeau qui est très
lourd qui est causé par une politique
étrangère qui n'est pas la nôtre et qui
a coûté
et au liban intel perd économique et
financière il faut que la communauté
nationale prend en considération et doit
nous aider dans ce sens dans le sens
d'un support financier d'un côté d'un
autre côté dans le sens d'aider le liban
à faire leur pays
merci beaucoup gibran bassil d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
l'ancien ministre libanais des affaires
étrangères
un chef du courant patriotique libre
merci à vous